bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour ce
premier journal de la saison sur tv fil
78 ce 1er septembre j'espère que vous
avez passé un bel été nous allons
revenir
du lundi au vendredi vous en avez
l'habitude sur l'actualité locale voici
donc les titres de ce mardi 300 de 1872
c'est le nombre d'élèves avoir repris le
chemin de l'école ce matin dans ce
département
nous reviendrons sur les enjeux de la
rentrée mais aussi sur le baptême du feu
des enseignants stagiaires comment
vivaient-ils leurs débuts et comment
sont ils préparés à accueillir nos
enfants lui aussi fait ses premiers pas
mais en tant que préfet serge morvan
vient d'être nommé à la tête du
département portrait de celui qui
officiait jusqu'à présent auprès du
secrétaire d'état à la réforme
territoriale
et puis l'invité ce soir bertrand de
créer le président du medef des yvelines
avec lui il sera question de la rentrée
économique des attentes des chefs
d'entreprise alors que vient de se
refermer à jouy en josas l'université
d'été du syndicat des patrons un
anniversaire pour débuter celui de la
disparition de louis xiv le 1er
septembre 1715 le roi soleil s'éteignait
à plusieurs événements sont organisés
cette semaine pour honorer le plus
célèbre des monarques concert de horgues
dîner royal et même course pédestre ce
sera dimanche prochain
un site internet a été ouvert le roi est
mort points comme vous y trouverez les
informations autour de l'exposition du
même nom qui ouvrira en octobre au
château de versailles les plus addicts
aux nouvelles technologies ont même vécu
cette journée sur twitter un compte
spécial a été lancée pour revivre la
disparition minute par minute du
souverain nous allons donc largement
parler de la rentrée scolaire à présent
avant d'évoquer le cas des élèves et des
enseignants comment avez vous vécu cette
reprise êtes vous heureux de retrouver
vos collègues de reprendre le travail
selon le site qapa.fr cette journée est
plutôt vécu comme les autres parler
français même s'il avoue se lever tout
de même un petit peu plus tôt pour se
préparer
nous sommes allés vérifier tout ça dans
les rues de saint quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui je suis contente la
demi-journée puis après les ennuis
commencent donc on a un peu moins
contents mais bon dans l'ensemble ça se
passe plutôt bien donc je me plains pas
des fois impatient pendant les vacances
de pâques
vers sa boîte on est des fois impatient
de reprendre les dossiers donc on
décroche pas vraiment et après on va en
boule on est content tout le monde est
là et ça repart pour une année quand on
est plutôt content de retrouver les
collègues on est reposé il a fait beau
et puis on a envie que l'activité
économique redémarre pour pouvoir mieux
repartir on va commencer l'année
prochaine si on est quand même content
oui contente mais bon pour prendre le
rythme tout simplement j'aime mon
travail alors ça ne dérange pas de
revenir travailler
voilà la première journée alain tout
coule youpi au regard du calendrier
permettant le mois de décembre
la rentrée a été parfois un peu plus
compliqué pour les élèves après deux
mois de vacances il faut reprendre donc
ses bonnes habitudes il était je vous le
disais tout à l'heure 300 2007 108 172
pardon dans le département ce matin des
collégiens des lycéens et des élèves de
primaire à reprendre le chemin de
l'école face à à peu près de vingt mille
enseignants des enseignants inquiets
dans le second degré avec la mise en
place progressive de la réforme du
collège qui misent sur
l'interdisciplinarité l'autonomie mais
qui prévoit aussi la suppression des
sections bilangues par exemple un
mouvement de grève a été annoncée par
les syndicats pour le mois d'octobre
dans le premier degré moindre angoisse
même s'il y aura quelques nouveautés
notamment l'enseignement moral et
civique nous en parlerons dans notre
édition de demain plus en détail avec le
directeur de l'académie de versailles
pour le moment écoutez ses élèves et
leurs parents à la sortie des écoles
justement la question du temps à me
poser alors comment ça s'est passé
on a fait des matches on a écrit dans
les cahiers on a fait des coloriages
on a joué fait des activités a été
impeccable rentrer au cp donc ça a été
non il ya eu des pleurs de la haine de
la petite fille de l'est de la bande
s'était bien passé l'état oui la peur
des parents toujours on continue à
parler de rentrée scolaire du côté des
enseignants nous avons voulu savoir
comment était former les professeurs de
première année dans les yvelines chaque
année ils font leur pré rentrée dès le
mois d'août 4 jours pour les accompagner
lors donner de précieux conseils florane
parfait et yves berger pour les images
plus étudiants mais pas encore
enseignant ses 360 professeurs des
écoles stagiaires évinois sont
rassemblés dès la fin du mois d'août
pour faire leur prérentrée au programme
de cette première journée une conférence
et des ateliers afin de les orienter sur
leurs missions
on a plus de renseignements concernant
notre rentrée donc comment va se
dérouler
le
le moi de le mois de septembre notamment
parce que c'est pas toujours évident
voilà on entre dans le métier donc c'est
bien d'avoir des informations
la première étape de ces quatre jours
d'accueil vise aussi à les rassurer
à partir de ce 1er septembre ils
enseigneront hamiton dans l'une des
quarante écoles du département
quand on dit que mardi les élèves
arrivent et qu'on ne connaît toujours
pas le niveau dans lequel on va on va
intervenir c'est un petit peu angoissant
mais bon c'est un métier d'adaptation
donc on est tout de suite dans le vif du
sujet c'est assez stimulant pour ses
futurs professeurs dont la majorité a
moins de 30 ans l'accent est mis sur le
tutorat
tout au long de l'année chacun sera
encadré par un professeur des écoles
titulaire ainsi qu'un universitaire nos
tuteurs qui va venir l'observer à pas se
contenter de lui faire un rapport à
créer ça permet un suivi beaucoup plus
régulier et à un accompagnement pour
voir fonctionner concrètement sur le
terrain
le département est un des plus
importants en termes d'élèves et
d'enseignants 8500 professeurs sont
répartis dont le premier et le second
degré sur les trente et une
circonscription des yvelines
voilà pour l'aspect technique de cette
formation des enseignants stagiaires
mais de la théorie à la pratique il ya
parfois un fossé un gap williams elle a
suivi
solène hier et aujourd'hui dans son
école des essarts le roi pour ses tout
premiers pas face à ses élèves
il est que les ide un petit peu 24
heures avant la rentrée solène
professeurs stagiaires en maternelle aux
essarts le roi reçoit ses derniers
conseils
tout doit être parfait avant le jour j
pour accueillir ces 28 élèves qui
effectueront leur première rentrée des
classes avec elle pour que les élèves se
sentent à l'aise avec des activités à
disposition voilà donc oui c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'important leur
proposer plusieurs choses plus aux
activités à la fois des jeux à la fois
de la manipulation pour la faire des
points à la classe l'agencé la classe et
préparer les activités mais aussi
réfléchir et mettre en place les projets
pour l'année avec toujours une petite
appréhension
c'est tout à nouveau une nouvelle
expérience donc oui un peu de stress de
de la découverte de l'inconnu mais en
même temps c'est très intéressant de
préparation supervisé par un professeur
titulaire qui est là aussi pour rassurer
un peu sa collègue
oui beaucoup de questions plus que
d'appréhension mais un stress de la
rentrée qui est parfaitement logique
il ya l'air d'avoir beaucoup de travail
avant et c'est intéressant parce que
justement c'est plus de les changes que
du suis pas là pour faire twitter
vingt quatre heures plus tard en ce jour
de rentrée la classe de solenn est
rempli et surtout il à mariani ce que
cela vient combler entre les ateliers
s'occuper de chaque enfant
une première journée de travail bien
remplie et même si tout était préparé
il ya toujours envers organisation de
débats
arrive l'heure du repas la jeune
professeur peut enfin souffler quelques
instants non ça s'est bien passé assez
peu de pleurs en fait fait tonner ils
sont tous intéressés aux ateliers ils
ont joué on a raconté une histoire dont
globalement bien quand même
cette année solène sera responsable de
sa classe deux jours par semaine le
reste du temps elle continue ses cours à
l'université
les avec 28 élèves il faudra encore un
peu de temps pour mémoriser tous les
prénoms bertrand de craie le président
du medef dans les yvelines est l'invité
de ce premier journal de rentrer bonsoir
et bienvenue en plateau bonne rentrée à
vous dans un instant on va évoquer
l'université d'été de votre organisation
patronale c'était la semaine dernière à
jouy en josas
et puisqu'il sera bien évidemment
question à d'économie un mot tout de
même pour terminer sur la rentrée
scolaire sur les prix des fournitures
scolaires
d'après le baromètre annuel de
l'association familles de france le prix
moyen de la rentrée s'élève cette année
à 190 euros 42 centimes une hausse de
seulement 0 7% par rapport à 2014
c'est donc plutôt la stabilité qui est
de mise et le dix mois ne s'est rendu
auprès des commerçants qui s'attendent
aussi à quelques derniers jours de ruck
montrent pas de prix on maintient le mât
prix klein dernière certains promotion
assure encore plus intéressant c'est le
même priant on n'a pas augmenté les prix
ont négocié mais avec les fabricants et
on
on essaie de vous maintient le prix et
si nécessaire on baisse notre marche
vers temps de créer vous êtes vous même
en dehors de vos fonctions de
responsable du medef dans le département
gérant d'un supermarché
les prix des fournitures scolaires on
est plutôt sur une stabilisation
globalement nous confirme cela jusqu'en
chine cela ces pages et une fonction
plutôt alimentaire donc pas tout à fait
deux arrêts mais j'ai aussi des futurs
scolaire en petit nombre et et en cela
je suis donc romain centrales on est
plutôt dans cet axe là d'ailleurs
peut-être un peu élargie en parler des
fournitures scolaires et vous l'avez
fait remarquer vous n'avez pas tant de
fournitures scolaires que ça dans votre
établissement en plus de produits
alimentaires
là aussi on est sur une stabilisation
des prix ou lcd augmentation des
diminutions comment ça se passe alors
parce que ça reflète aussi la vitalité
économique un en france par exemple que
maintenant on va on va éliminer tous les
tous les produits de court son lait des
fruits et légumes
enfin vous dites qu'ils sont assez de
2,2 de péripéties cet été qui obéissent
à des cours donc là qui ont des voeux
des volatilités soins demande mondiale
d'un faiblement
pour le reste il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est la guerre des
prix dans la discussion est une réalité
elle a plutôt tendance à tirer vers le
bas basskin crise économique et qu'il
faut plutôt baisser les prix pour
continuer à attirer les clients je vois
je ne le crois pas alors maintenant
c'est personnel je pense que la guerre
des prix est mortifère pour la société
elle est immédiatement on les séduisante
parce qu'elle permet d'avoir des prix
bas et donc d'attirer des clients sur le
long terme
effectivement on va attirer sur la
justice ou les fournisseurs sur les
salaires sur tout ça et pour moi c'est
d'une spirale négative alors que des
prix un peu plus haut qui serait
effectivement on permettra pour l'achat
d'un mac joué par les ja mais
permettrait peut-être plus d'emplois
plus de stabilité aux entreprises les
plus de gains pour les est difficile à
faire passer comme message malgré tout
auprès du consommateur est un message de
réalité c'est un message savez ça fait
partie dé trouver de pierre gattaz en
parler on va parler de notre ère
était il n'a pas le duvet de vérité il
faut pas peur de faire des vrais constat
si vous voulez aujourd'hui se mettre
seulement le pouvoir d'achat en tête
c'était les deux chômage civile pouvoir
d'achat ça devient autre chose
ce qui est plus important c'est d'avoir
un boulot et d'avoir des entreprises qui
ne servent pas pour moi ça c'est plus et
puis fondamentale tous les ans on aura
joué un jeu aux as donc le syndicat des
patrons organise son université d'été
c'est de ce sujet dont on va parler à
présent rendez vous très médiatisé
souvent marqué par des déclarations
polémiques cette année le ministre de
l'économie emmanuel macron ainsi
provoqué la colère des socialistes il a
critiqué les 35 heures mais il a nuancé
un petit peu ses propos quelques jours
plus tard votre avis sur ces
déclarations et ce retrait un petit peu
de mâcon qu'il est revenu sur ses propos
sur les gentils déclarations du ministre
socialiste l'autre d'été on est habitué
après le jem et entreprendrait dernière
alors maintenant entre la déclaration
d'amour où le geste ce qui nous
intéresse ce sont les actes qui vont
suivre plus précisément sur ce qu'a dit
le al-bakr on sait que les 35 heures ça
ne marche pas tout le monde sait que le
gâteau ne peux pas me partager que c'est
la croissance qui permettra de réunir
l'emploi donc évidemment les dogmatiques
du parti socialiste ont hurlé mais mais
mais parce qu'ils sont peu m
mais macron a raison mais quand vous
l'avez entendu revenir un petit peu sur
ses propos en disant c'est pas tout à
fait ça que je voulais dire les 35
heures c'est pas si mal
ménager un peu la chèvre et le chou sur
les politiques ça vous déçoit mais elle
me déçoit
parce qu'il a été très applaudie
emmanuel macron lors de ses premières
déclarations j'irai jusqu'à des cons et
qu'on est tellement habitué que donc
j'ai fait un disque sur ce cas là qui
est intéressant c'est au moins on sait
qu'ils ont on a au moins un ministre qui
est kabyle lucidité non ça c'est déjà
pas mal
la réalité des 35 heures pour revenir
sur ce sujet des 35 heures la réalité
des 35 heures dans une entreprise par
exemple comme la vôtre ça signifie quoi
ça permet d'embaucher plus vous
embauchez moi ça vous coûte plus cher
moins bien comment ça fonctionne parce
que c'est critiquer mais derrière tout
ça c'est quoi la réalité des 35 heures
dans un établissement un supermarché
comme la réalité des 35 heures c'est que
c'est un dogme stupide stupide parce que
vous avez des 80 populations différentes
et vouloir obliger systématiquement tout
le monde
hommes femmes jeunes mariées
célibataires a trahi le même nombre
d'heures par semaine c'est d'abord c'est
liberticide
mais si stupide on a aujourd'hui elles
ont bien fait bien rigoler tout de même
il faut bien des limites des normes
khelil et nord qui faisait leur ont les
mains tandis qu'on fixe et l'armée pape
des normes
moi je pense que la suisse se fixer de
gré à gré moi j'ai des salariés dans mon
établissement des salariés très précis
de mères de famille qui ont un boulot
d'appoint la soie mâle qui travaillent
elles ne veulent pas avoir à temps
complet elles veulent avoir parce que
son nom un complément de salaire
j'ai ce cas là les étudiants et ça ne
pouvait pas le faire
non c'est compliqué dans ces cas on peut
le faire en moins on peut le faire mais
j'ai aussi des jeunes hommes
célibataires qui préfèrent à l'averse
qui pourraient travailler 40 heures 45
heure parce que parce qu'ils décident
ils sont en phase de construction de 2 2
lors de lors de leur patrimoine et
qu'ils auront envie de gagner plus parce
que c'est la question que j'allais vous
pouvez derrière ils gagneraient plus
dans ces cas là pour moi trop ça met un
terme à tout ça pour moi pour moi ce
attendait cela n'était pas travailler
plus pour gagner pareil
non non c'est un équilibre c'est un
équilibre c'est un équilibre à avoir si
vous voulez aujourd'hui si vous voulez
la vérité économique sa levée de vérité
aujourd'hui l'entreprise peut rémunérer
une masse de salaire d'un pourcentage
généralement on sait exactement par type
de profession quel est le seuil critique
à ne pas dépasser
au delà on est dans le rouge nous
puisque dans le rouge elle ferme quand
elles ferment et licencient tout le
monde
tout le monde est perdant tout le monde
est perdant l'université d'été qui vient
donc de se refermer c'était la semaine
dernière et ce sont les jeunes qui était
au coeur des discussions s'étaient la
thématique de cette année
plus globalement avant de parler des
jeunes on dit souvent que l'université
d'été du medef d'une année sur l'autre
se ressemblent tout simplement parce
qu'il y est toujours question de baisser
les charges de revenir sur les 35 heures
ça ça vous énerve
alors oui lorsque vous entendez ça je
sais que ça vous énerve on en a parlé
juste avant que l'émission commence
alors d'abord elle 60 pas tout
elles sont alors si elles se ressemblent
toutes deux leur excellence
dans la qualité de la participants là
mais lorsqu'on entend semblait postale
ce discours bon c'est le sénat était
formulée le jeune à la jeunesse c'est un
message d'espoir et d'optimisme sur
l'avenir pour dire aux autres que les
patrons sont optimistes qui veulent voir
l'avenir plus clément mais pourquoi est
ce que nous parlons toujours des mêmes
choses parce que nous ne sommes pas
entendus il est évident aujourd'hui et
maintenant ça empire et que les charges
qui pèsent sur le travail lourdes
d'europe
c'est un constat mais je pose la même
question partons d'un exemple concret le
vôtre pour sept chefs d'entreprise les
charges sociales charges patronales ça
représente quoi fait ça nous empêche
d'en boîtier jeu complètement non mais
complètement parce que c'est là moi j'ai
fui je vais proposer un jour un ministre
je lui ai dit écoutez je suis prêt à
embaucher à l'euro l'euro des chômeurs
contre mes charges mais recommandées
chaque bataille d'endor dans les 100 %
de salaire que madonna salariale que je
pèse danger une part importante des
charges patronales si je vous prends un
chômeur ou le payer plus et moi ce que
vous avez vu le pays vous mélangez en
charge donc d'affaires neutre pour vous
par contre moi je m'engage à embaucher
la différence nous avons un chômeur on a
même au travail ça a été accueillie
comment il m'a dit alors et je touche je
ne dirai pas le nom du ministre en
question et ma démission c'est ça
monsieur de craie nous vous donnerons la
main c'était cette année un ministre qui
est venu pouvoir y en a eu cinq ans elle
n'avait pas pu l année dernière on vous
donnerait la main il est bouclé pour
nous d'avoir des chômeurs que deux
hommes assurent emploi je vous donne pas
le nom du ministre on y parle université
d'été la présence retour sur les
différentes thématiques étaient abordés
la façon dont tout cela s'est déroulé
c'était donc la semaine dernière à jouy
en josas sur deux jours formidables
jeunesse en baptisant son université
d'été ainsi le medef entende et faire de
la place aux jeunes mais si les
déclarations d'amour ne manquez pas sur
scène pierre gattaz n'a pas oublié pour
autant de lits
ses attentes envers le gouvernement les
citations du travail à réformer
fiscalité allégée et complexités
administratives réglementaires à
continuer de travailler avec avec
ténacité herculéenne et le gouvernement
qui mène qui mènera à bien cette réforme
sera historique à travers le thème de la
jeunesse se sont en tout cas les grands
défis mondiaux qui ont été abordés
pendant ces deux jours démographie ou
encore digitalisation de l'économie un
sujet évoqué en présence des présidents
en france de facebook et de google
laurent soulier et nick leader parmi les
multiples conférences celle consacrée à
l'environnement alors que se tiendra à
paris dans deux mois la coop 21
rencontres piloté par les nations unies
sur les changements climatiques
professeur de philosophie maire-adjoint
de versailles françois xavier bellamy
est intervenu sur le sujet au fond nous
nous vivons dans un monde qui est
profondément marquée par une forme
d'individualisme
ce qui est très important c'est que les
jeunes soient bien conscients que dans
la mention dans l'innovation dans la
créativité
il ya des vrais gisements d'activité de
development sens profond du terme qui
soit en même temps un développement
durable à l'heure de la mondialisation
et pour s'attarder sur la place des
jeunes des pays du moyen-orient ou
encore d'afrique dans l'économie de
demain
sa majesté la reine rania al abdullah de
jordanie et l'artiste youssou ndour
aujourd'hui conseiller auprès du
président sénégalais avait fait le
déplacement
l'afrique d'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus la
fiq d'avant la file d'aujourd'hui ses
8,8 gagnant gagnant la fiq tout est à
construire
mais nous voulons participer à la
construction de notre continent
d'ailleurs la fixer pas un pays c'est un
continent ce sont des relations il faut
respecter quand même les pays de
nombreuses déclarations autant
d'ambition mais difficile de savoir ce
que pensent et les principaux concernés
les jeunes plutôt absent de ce
rendez-vous pour ceux qui ont assisté à
l'université du medef
il faudra maintenant passer de la parole
aux actes qu'est ce que j'attends de mes
aînés j'attends qui m'apprennent
vraiment à savoir faire face chaque jour
à ce qui va nous attendre et surtout
dans le monde de l'entreprise
l inquiétude parce que le comme le monde
aujourd'hui le monde d'entreprises en
france marche moins bien qui le fuit
l'homme qui marche il ya 20 ou 30 ans on
a un peu peur de boire trop étroit de
travail en tant que jeune plus tard mais
mais on a confiance à la france on pense
que tout doit passer quand même
les jeunes qui sont confiants malgré
tout mais tout de même un petit peu
d'inquiétude pour trouver un emploi je
ferai juste une parenthèse y en avait
pas beaucoup des jeunes sur l'université
d'été du medef
normal des jeunes les entreprises n'a
pas encore beaucoup ils sont jeunes ils
vont apprendre ils seront je sais pas
que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui seront
demain c'est le 9 mai mais la réalité
des jeunes en tout cas pour le monde du
travail
aujourd'hui on dit souvent les jeunes
quittent la france parce que c'est plus
simple d'aller travailler ailleurs vous
constatez est ce que oui on le
département les entrepreneurs vous
remonte ce genre de choses alors
vraiment pu déjà au fait je suis aussi
peur eux
j'ai trois enfants dont des trois
enfants il m'a inquiété à l'étranger
c'est moi qui lui avais dit non c'est du
smarties l'arbitrage est là constaté
pourquoi parce qu'elle a trouvé des
règles des clauses différente et elle
mène une très belle qu'à l'international
ce que sa fille à l'étranger bon c'est
une réalité
aujourd'hui j'ai autour de moi beaucoup
de jeunes qui partent travailler un
monde qui part travailleurs parce que
parce qu'ils ne trouvent pas leur
établissement alors maintenant je n'ai
pas de ceux qui vous disent attention
pas pareil vous il faut aussi construire
c'est vous dire que le bdf vous parle
parce que les jeunes on veut les garder
nous il va danser on veut les garder
chez nous on veut les avoir avec nous on
est très engagé dans l'apprentissage
parce qu'on y croit énormément
on a eu une tribune total ce visage on a
une signature un impact d'engagement
pour le supérieur aussi avec les
universités différentes écoles pour
faciliter l'intégration des jeunes d'un
truc là c est d'ailleurs le meilleur sur
dix il va participer avec les saint
quentin a pas mal de choses pour
justement intégrer les jeunes et et nous
travaillons énormément parce que ce sont
deux mains les valeurs de demain la
jeunesse ce sera les actifs de demain
donc c'est nous devons nous investir le
président du medef divine invités de ce
journal une toute dernière question oui
non pour terminer michel combes ex pdg
alcatel lucent qui pourrait empêcher
presque 14 millions d'euros pour son
départ comme le vice-président du medef
vous aussi vous êtes choqués mais plus
que cela d'avoir d'abord un journée
assez en tant que patron exclusif est
pas tranché entre après j'ai créé mon
entreprise elle m'appartient
cet homme est un salarié il vient
salariés comme les autres leur cible
plutôt l'autre côté équipe type ou
quatre ans millions d'euros c'est
quasiment 10 mois je fais vivre 40
personnes avec ça je me paye je vis des
fournisseurs
c'est donc ça cesse mais parce que c'est
la seule réalité s'il vous plaît si
c'était un patron à part entière un
petit que vous ça vous aurez choisi
non parce que ce n'était pas un patron
comme moi n'aurait jamais pris un ticket
comme ça ils auraient vendu des actions
il aura un capital la seule
justification pour moi de l'argent
excessif entre guillemets c'est le
risque c'est parce qu'il a investi parce
que épi général on verrait les patrons
patrimoniaux généralement mon palgen
parachute patron c'est merci bertrand du
cray présidente du medef des yvelines
invité donc aujourd'hui pour 700 reprise
du journal de la rédaction merci à vous
et à bientôt
la du changement à la tête du
département durant l'été serge mans vont
à remplacer le préfet erard corbin de
montjoux au poste de préfet le passage
de relais entre les deux hommes s'est
fait à la fin du mois d'août
c'est son premier poste de préfet serge
morvan 56 ans prend la tête du
département des yvelines jusqu'à présent
homme-orchestre de la réforme
territoriale en tant que directeur de
cabinet du secrétaire d'état chargé de
ce dossier
il accompagnera le redécoupage des
intercommunalités qui sera effectif dès
le 1er janvier
parmi les autres dossiers qui
l'attendent la création d'une aire de
grand passage des gens du voyage dans le
sud des yvelines dossier toujours
reporté par ses prédécesseurs
il devra aussi se pencher sur des
questions de sécurité avec le phénomène
de radicalisation de certains jeunes
musulmans phénomène en augmentation
notamment aux zones prioritaires son
prédécesseur erard corbin de mangoux
vient lui d'être affectés à la cour des
comptes
il quitte le département sur une
victoire contre le maire front national
de mantes la jolie à sa demande la
justice vient de suspendre le projet de
ce dernier d'installer un poste de
police municipale sur l'emplacement
d'une future mosquée on en vient aux
sports avant de refermer cette première
édition la 18e édition du paris brest
paris s'est déroulée à la fin du moins
d'août tous les quatre ans les amateurs
de cyclotourisme parcours 1200 km et une
fois de plus saint quentin en yvelines
était au coeur de l'événement plus de
6000 inscrits venus de 66 pays de 1500
bénévoles record d'affluence battu le
paris brest paris n'a plus grand chose à
prouver en terme de notoriété sans
esprit de compétition
uniquement pour l'amour de la petite
reine les cyclotouristes se réunissent
tous les quatre ans à la fin du mois
d'août
et cela dure depuis plus d'un siècle la
première édition remonte à 1891
parmi les habitués le président de la
fédération de cyclotourisme c'était sa
onzième participation
bah quand j'ai commencé avec 700
participants y avait personne à bord des
routes
voilà on dormait dans la paille vous
voyez quand même que les temps après
changer quoi donc
et depuis tout ce que j'ai fait la météo
est différente cette année on a eu une
météo exceptionnelle un petit peu raté
sur le dernier jour mais bon vraiment
c'était d'être les conditions idéales
pour le faire cette randonnée qui est
déjà difficile sur le plan le relief
si le paris brest paris est un plaisir
il n'en demeure pas moins difficile il
faut faire face aux intempéries à la
fatigue et aux imprévisibles problème
technique mais je crois que ces deux là
avant tout une question d'entraînement
enfin il est l'entraînement porte c'est
quand même sur ye l'entraînement
physique mais il ya également
l'entraînement mental une aventure comme
paris il fait 1 brest paris se prépare
aussi bien physiquement que mentalement
il ya la souffrance
il n'y a pas que du plaisir les mots
aguerris ont quatre jours pour boucler
le parcours il faut en moyenne 85 heures
pour accomplir les 1200 kilomètres et
traverser fougères loudéac ou encore
carré mais cette année l'allemand bjorn
lander a établi un nouveau temps de
référence 42 heures et 26 minutes au
début c'était facile sur les deux
premiers tiers
mais après les 80 derniers kilomètres
c'était plus dur mais ça va le vélo
était parfait les routes aussi le paris
brest paris reviendra à saint quentin en
yvelines en 2019 et l'on devrait une
fois de plus assisté à un défilé de
monture est de la plus classique à la
plus excentrique et notez déjà dans vos
agendas le retour du 7-8 sport dès lundi
7 septembre à 18h30 et à 19h30 michael
et demi d'euros vous attend pour le coup
d'envoi de la nouvelle saison demain
dans le journal nous parlerons une fois
de plus de cette rentrée à des classes
avec le directeur académique et des
yvelines il sera en plateau pour dresser
un premier bilan rendez vous à 18h pour
le direct 19h pour la première diffusion
et en 2h30 également à suivre sur notre
antenne ce journal est à retrouver aussi
sur le site internet excellente soirée